[Music]
my generation is the junk food
generation raised on gushers and
capri-sun double stuffed Oreos and
dollar many McNuggets forget fun size
we ate fruit by the foot by the foot
high fructose corn syrup was added to
coke in 1980 when the first millennials
were born and in what cannot be a
coincidence dunkaroos were discontinued
the year I graduated from college
suddenly I was an adult food science has
given us the signals that humans evolved
to crave salt sugar fat but without the
substance they were once associated with
in nature real nutrition junk food is
engineered so that we literally can't
resist once you pop you can't stop isn't
empty marketing its evolutionary science
junk food is engineered junk food has
divorced the signals we crave from the
substance our bodies need it has made us
sick as a result but social media over
the last decade and a half has given us
something worse junk food for the Soul
Millennials first we fell for fun dip
then we fell for Facebook humans crave
connection deep personal connection with
those around us dozens of scientific
studies indicate what we all intuitively
know when our lives are filled with
meaningful social interaction were
happier we're healthier we live longer
so hyper so hypothetically we should be
lucky to live in this age of
connectivity we're through text and
whatsapp and Instagram I can feel
connected to nearly everyone I've ever
met
and yet we had this crisis of loneliness
in the 70s and 80s between 10 and
20% of Americans said they regularly or
frequently felt lonely by 2010 that was
40% between 1985 and 2004 the percent of
Americans who said they did not feel
like they had a single friend they could
rely on to discuss important matters
more than doubled from 20% to 43% not a
single friend the fact that we are so
connected and it feels so alone is only
a paradox to someone who's never used
social media who's never spent a
Saturday night lying on their unmade bed
scrolling through Instagram because
obviously there's a difference between
the virtual time we spend together and
the real after spending real time with
my friends I don't feel empty I don't
feel guilty I don't tell myself I'm
gonna stop seeing my friends so much and
if I do it'll only be for five minutes
and only if I've been really productive
Facebook Instagram snapchat they're
engineered to give us the signals we
associate with friendship sharing
stories liking pictures remembering a
birthday but without the substance of
true connection we talk about Instagram
celebrities as if they're unique and
creating these filtered artificial
versions of themselves online but we all
do it
celebrities just get paid for it we
complain about fake news on Facebook
Facebook was built on fake news it was
just usually about ourselves it's no
surprise that the heaviest users of
social media report twice as much social
social isolation as those who don't use
it at all it's no coincidence that were
the generation that invented FOMO of
course I'm gonna fear missing out if I
spend hours a day staring at definitive
evidence of me missing out at root these
technologies are designed for our
engagement but not with each other
but the technology itself Sean Parker
the first president of Facebook and the
founder of Napster frame the question as
how do we we being Facebook consume as
much of your time and conscious
attention as possible and it's answer
create a social validation feedback loop
when I post a picture I keep checking to
see how many likes I get every refresh
is like another pull the social
validation slot-machine and every like
gives me that little hit of dopamine a
little signal of friendship and social
approval that I crave eventually it
wears off and so I post another picture
another quarter in the slots it's an
addictive feedback loop that in Parker's
words creates exploits a vulnerability
in human psychology and keeps us on the
platform once you pop you can't stop
it makes me wonder if video games candy
crush or a Call of Duty are similarly
doing more to deliver the signals of
accomplishment than the substance of
having an impact in the world it makes
me wonder if dating apps are doing more
together to deliver the signals of
romantic interactions and the substance
of forming real relationships it even
makes me wonder if music festivals and
$34 workout classes are now giving us
the signals of community and and purpose
that we once looked for in spiritual
practice I mean it's called soul cycle
all the signals we crave but do they
have this substance a friend as defined
by Facebook is no more a real friend
than Doritos Tacos locos is real food
it's empty calories it leaves us
hungrier for true connection than when
we started
Mark Zuckerberg for his part is not
blind to this phenomenon earlier this
year he wrote he now wants us to have
more meaningful social interactions so
the time we spend on Facebook is time
well spent as a result of the changes
he's made total time on the platform
actually fell by 15 minutes per person
per week is it a healthier Facebook or
just a slightly less addicting one yes
technology can create community but only
if it's facilitating interaction and not
crowding it out
if junk food and capsule eights the
problem may be food can also offer the
solution because if we're the junk food
generation were also the farmers market
generation we recognize the junk food
was delivering empty signal and was
making us sick and is that sort of
radical reorientation we've taken with
regards to food that we now need to
extend to our social lives as well in
the end we have to be willing to be
dissatisfied because the greatest threat
is not that we get nothing from social
media but that we get just enough signal
never to hunt for that substance that
farmville makes us feel just productive
enough that we never produce anything
the tinder makes dating just easy enough
we have a formal relationship that
Instagram makes us feel just connected
enough to leave us truly alone a few
weeks ago one of my best friends from
growing up had a birthday and we're all
scattered across the country now but
over a whatsapp group we sent out our
happy birthdays and I typed one out
under the desk during class with a long
string of emojis and it was funny it was
fine it was nice but that night back my
room sitting on the edge of my bed I
picked up my phone and I called him and
we conference day and our other friends
and we talked we laughed and we made fun
of each other we can sold each other and
great it was real at the end of the call
after my other friends had hopped off he
said to me Mike it's just great to hear
your voice
I still need gushers sometimes I still
go on Facebook more often than I like to
admit but now at least I can treat it
for what it is junk food for the Soul
[Applause]
[Music]